[Music]
hey pardon me sorry thank you of the
wrong car you've emailed for an
appointment two days in a row tell me
what's going on I've never seen a case
like this before
23 identities live in Kevin's body did
something happen there's a flower on the
pillows a flower in the bathroom like
we're important who is that maybe she
can help us don't worry he knows what
you're here for
is not allowed to touch you he knows
that my name is Hedwig I have read thugs
how old are you 9 the human brain is the
most complex object in the universe the
only way we're getting out of here hunt
you the clever one Harry could you help
us ok I have to wind up in my room maybe
you could show us that's here now it's
closed now it's open did you think it
was a ruiner so you could leave an
individual with multiple personalities
can change their body chemistry with
their thoughts
someone's coming for you what will
happen when he unlocks the potential of
his brain there is no limit to what he
can become and now is a sacred night you
will be in the presence of something
greater the world will understand now
the Beast is real he's done awful things
to people and he'll do awful things to
you
[Music]